SHOOTS.
BLOCKED.
RANTANEN TO THE PUCK.
BACK OUT TO MAKAR.
NOW RANTANEN.
TO MAKAR.
SHOOTS.
BLOCKED.
DEFLECTED WIDE.
>> Eddie: MacKINNON WANTS THE
PUCK.
TAKING AWAY THE PASSING LANE.
>> Kenny: HE WAS GOING FOR IT A
MOMENT AGO.
HERE'S MACKINNON.
TO DARLINGS.
ACROSS FOR RANTANEN."
RANTANEN SHOOTS, HE SCORES!
[HORN]
>> Eddie: THE PUCK RETRIEVAL A
ON THIS POWER PLAY WAS
SENSATIONAL.
ANY LOOSE PUCK THE AVALANCHE
WERE ABLE TO GET IT.
THEY FINALLY GOT THE PUCK OVER
TO MACKINNON.
DOES A LITTLE SPINORAMA, PLAYS A
LITTLE PITCH AND-AND CATCH WITH
MAKAR AND THEN MIKKO RANTANEN
PULLS IT.
WATCH HOW HE CHANGES THE ANGLE
RIGHT HERE.
HE GETS IT.
HE PULLS IT INTO HIS BODY, AND
THEN GOES SHORT SIDE A.
RIGHT OFF OF THE LEFT SHOULDER
AND INTO THE TOP OF THE NET.